Salut les Épicurieux.
Sur les réseaux sociaux et sur Youtube,
vous m'avez posé de nombreuses questions
sur la Terre, le ciel et l'espace,
une thématique qui me met vous le savez
des étoiles plein les yeux.
Décollage imminent !
Question de Sandrine Grausem :
"Comment se forment les aurores boréales?"
C'est beau, une aurore boréale.
Elle se forme dans les régions situées
autour du pôle Nord et elle naît
de la rencontre entre le vent solaire
et notre atmosphère.
Le vent solaire, c'est
un flux de particules chargées
en énergie que le soleil
expulse dans l'espace.
Ces particules sont pour la plupart
arrêtées par notre champ magnétique terrestre,
mais une partie s'engouffre
au niveau des pôles.
Et lorsqu'elle rencontre les gaz
qui constituent notre atmosphère,
ça fait des étincelles,
ou plutôt des lumières colorées,
celles qui sont caractéristiques
des aurores boréales.
Le vert, le rouge, parfois le violet
ou le rose embrassent alors le ciel.
Je n'en ai jamais vu,
mais je ne désespère pas.
Les vents solaires, en effet,
ne sont pas réguliers.
Il y a des cycles qui durent 11 ans.
Or, depuis décembre 2019, nous sommes
entrés dans un nouveau cycle.
Son maximum est prévu pour 2025.
Les aurores boréales
devraient donc être plus nombreuses
et plus visibles jusque
dans les régions du nord de l'Europe.
Je compte bien en profiter.
Question de Marwane Seladji.
"Que se passerait il si la couche
d'ozone disparaissait ?"
La couche d'ozone est située à
une altitude comprise entre 20 et 30 km.
Comme son nom l'indique,
elle est constituée d'ozone,
des molécules d'ozone.
"O3" de leur petit nom.
Des assemblages de trois
atomes d'oxygène.
Cette couche assez fine est vitale.
En effet, elle arrête 98% des rayons
ultraviolets les plus dangereux.
Sans ce bouclier,
la vie sur Terre serait menacée.
L'Homme, bien sûr,
car ces rayons déstructurent l'ADN
et transforment les cellules saines
en cellules cancéreuses.
Mais pas seulement l'Homme.
Ces rayons endommagerait aussi l'ADN
de la faune et de la flore
à une très grande échelle.
D'après une étude récente,
c'est ce qui s'est passé
il y a environ 360 millions d'années.
Les chercheurs ont démontré
qu'un trou dans la couche
d'ozone a provoqué la disparition
de 70 à 80% des espèces.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'extinction
du Dévonien avant celle des dinosaures,
qui a eu lieu il y a 66
millions d'années.
Une question d'Elaine :
"D'où vient l'expression
faire des plans sur la comète ?"
Eh bien Hélène, en
posant cette question,
vous n'avez pas fait
un plan sur la comète?
On utilise cette expression
quand quelqu'un fait des projets
qui ont peu de chances de se réaliser.
Un jour, j'irai sur Mars, par exemple.
Vous le savez, il y a peu
de chances que ça arrive.
C'est donc un plan sur la comète.
Rien d'étonnant à cette
association d'idées.
Voir une comète briller dans le ciel
est aussi très improbable.
Il s'agit d'un événement rare
avant d'avoir les moyens
d'observation et de calculs
dont on dispose aujourd'hui.
Il était en effet quasiment impossible
pour les astronomes
de prévoir la trajectoire
et donc le passage près
de la Terre de ces astres brillants,
constitués de glace et de roches.
Et ce n'est peut-être pas un
hasard si cette expression est née
à la fin du XIXème siècle.
C'est l'époque des grands romans
de Jules Verne, l'Espace,
les étoiles font rêver
et plusieurs comètes sont observées
dans le ciel au cours des années 1880.
L'une d'elles, en septembre
1882, était même visible
en plein jour et à l'œil nu.
Pas étonnant, donc, que les comètes
aient stimulé l'imagination
et qu'elles se soient retrouvées
dans une expression du langage courant.
Une question de Livio, huit ans,
qui est très observateur :
"Pourquoi en voiture la nuit,
on croit que la lune nous suit ?"
Je suis sûr que vous avez déjà eu
cette impression comme Livio.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
une illusion d'optique.
En fait, notre cerveau est manipulé.
Je m'explique. Lorsqu'on roule
en voiture, on aperçoit des objets fixes
dans la des poteaux, par exemple.
On les voit d'abord plus ou moins
loin devant nous, puis à côté et enfin
derrière la voiture, en fonction
du temps que l'on met à les dépasser.
Notre cerveau est capable de déduire
à quelle distance ils se trouvaient.
Si maintenant une voiture roule
à nos côtés un petit moment,
il est aussi capable, notre cerveau,
d'en conclure qu'elle roule
à la même vitesse
et dans la même direction que nous.
Mais le problème avec la Lune, c'est
qu'elle se situe beaucoup, beaucoup
plus loin qu'un poteau.
Du coup, même si on roule
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres,
on ne la dépasse jamais.
Notre cerveau va donc en conclure
à tort, que la Lune se déplace
dans la même direction que nous, comme
une voiture qui roulerait à nos côtés.
Question de la chose 951 :
"Si une météorite de la même taille
que celle qui a tué les dinosaures
s'abattait sur la Terre, survivrait-on ?"
Eh bien, mieux vaudrait ne pas se trouver
à proximité du point d'impact.
La météorite dont parle la chose
et qui est entrée
en collision avec la Terre
il y a 65 millions d'années
mesurait une dizaine
de kilomètres de diamètre.
Elle a creusé un cratère
de 150 kilomètres de large.
La distance Paris 3
est de 30 km de profondeur.
Elle a provoqué un raz-de-marée
29 000 fois plus puissant
que le tsunami qui a frappé
l'Indonésie en 2004.
Des vagues de plus
de 100 mètres de hauteur.
Genre, "Le jour d'après".
Surtout, les scientifiques pensent
que la météorite
s'est abattue sur une réserve de soufre
ou de pétrole, ce qui a dégagé
d'immenses quantités de gaz
et de particules dans l'atmosphère.
Des gaz qui ont rapidement enveloppé
toute la terre, provoquant
une chute de température
et plongeant notre planète
dans l'obscurité
pendant une dizaine d'années.
Vous connaissez la fin de l'histoire?
Après 165 millions d'années de règne
absolu, les dinosaures ont disparu.
Sachez que ce genre d'astéroïdes
est assez rare et qu'aujourd'hui,
ces bolides sont surveillés
de très, très près.
Aucun ne devrait s'approcher de la Terre
avant très longtemps.
Vous pouvez donc dormir
sur vos deux oreilles.
Il y a des trucs beaucoup plus petits
qui sont plus dangereux.
Question d' Edourardga :
"Pourquoi la Terre ne tourne-t-elle
pas tout le temps
à la même vitesse ? "
C'est vrai, la terre
ne tourne pas toujours sur elle
même, à la même vitesse.
Du coup, les journées ne durent pas
toujours exactement
24 heures, ce qui fait 86 400 secondes.
Faites le calcul 60 x 60 x 24 = 86 400.
En 2020, la journée
la plus courte a duré une milliseconde
et demi de moins. 1,46 millisecondes
pour être très précis.
A l'inverse, la plus longue a duré 1,62
millisecondes de plus.
Pourquoi ces variations?
Eh bien, parce que le mouvement
de notre planète est influencé
par celui de son noyau interne
et par les mouvements de l'atmosphère.
En 2020, la Terre a été
particulièrement rapide,
ce qui a étonné les scientifiques,
car sur le long terme,
elle a tendance à ralentir, cette fois
à cause de l'attraction de la Lune.
Les masses d'eau
déplacées par les marées frottent en effet
contre la croûte terrestre et freinent
la rotation de notre planète.
Résultat : on estime qu'à l'époque des
dinosaures, il y a 70 millions d'années,
le jour ne durait que 23h30.
Patrick Glysher se demande
pourquoi Pluton n'est plus intégré
au système solaire.
Rassurez-vous, Pluton
appartient toujours au système solaire.
Le débat, Patrick, porte en fait
sur la nature même de Pluton.
Est-elle une planète ou non ?
D'abord considérée comme la neuvième
planète de notre système solaire, Pluton
a été officiellement rétrogradée en 2006
au rang de planète naine. Pourquoi?
Eh bien, contrairement aux huit planètes
de notre système solaire
Mercure, Vénus, la Terre, Mars,
Jupiter, Saturne, Uranus et Neptune
qui ont réussi à faire le ménage autour
d'elle, Pluton ne l'a pas fait.
Elle est entourée de milliers
d'objets célestes
qui appartiennent comme elles à ce qu'on
appelle la ceinture de Kuiper.
C'est pour cette raison que, d'après
l'Union astronomique internationale,
Pluton ne peut pas être considérée
comme une planète à part entière,
mais comme une planète naine.
Retrouvez "C'est
Jamy" du lundi au vendredi à 16h55
sur France 5 ou dès
maintenant sur France.tv.
Le lien est sous cette vidéo
et surtout, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
et activez la cloche. Faites-le savoir !